bien jean castex prévoit un retour à une
vie presque normale avec des fêtes de
famille pour donc noël et le 31 décembre
alors la baisse des contaminations se
poursuivant le pic épidémique ayant été
dépassée bien le confinement peut être
allégés alors l'ensemble des commerces
rouvrent ira bien le 28 novembre mais
avec un protocole renforcé
c'est à dire pas plus d'une personne par
huit mètres carrés un client je parle ou
alors un couple ou une personne avec
enfants et les magasins de plus de 400
mètres carrés devront compter les
clients ensuite les visites immobilière
pourront reprendre ainsi que certaines
activités des stations service des
stations pardon le des auto écoles
en revanche il n'y aura pas de bonne
surprise pour les bars et les
restaurants qui ne rouvriront que le 20
janvier
mais jean castex a annoncé qu'il allait
soutenir la filière qu'il allait créer
une année de la gastronomie en 2021 je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous allons très fortement accompagner
les professionnels de ce secteur
financièrement d'abord en veillant à ce
qu'ils puissent tenir le coup j'y
reviendrai
nous allons les aider par des marques de
solidarité en recourant le plus possible
à la vente de repas à emporter en leur
portant une attention individualisé
territoire par territoire en leur
offrant aussi des perspectives
d'abord en préparant avec eux les
conditions de réouverture dès que ce
virus sera maîtrisée et cela arrivera
alors la règle des 20 km et des trois
heures n'est pas pour aller voir sa
famille ou pour voir ses amis mais
du sport individuel pour pêcher et
chasser
sinon les les activités extrascolaires
en intérieur ou en extérieur reprendront
le 15 décembre mais les salles de sport
resteront fermés quant à la jauge des
salles de cultes on connaissait ce
chiffre de 30 personnes par
établissement mais elle pourrait être
augmenté au fil des semaines
également en fonction de la capacité des
établissements de culte les lieux
culturels enfin cinémas théâtres salles
de concerts rouvriront à partir du 15
décembre mais avec les mêmes règles que
pendant le couvre feu c'est à dire que
les spectacles du rv devront s'achever
avant 21h et puis le gouvernement a
détaillé également les aides qui seront
données apportées aux jeunes qui sont
très affectés par cette crise sanitaire
dernier dernier point les stations de
ski et bien elles seront ouvertes
c'est-à-dire que selon jean castex vous
pourrez aller respirer l'air pur mais
vous n'aurez pas le droit de faire du
ski car les remontées mécaniques seront
fermés voilà ce qu'on peut retenir de
cette conférence de jean castex